and a lot of the Boomers now are fly
like the boomers are flying in in in
large numbers now and the boomers are
flying to go visit and torture and
torment their children this is why
boomers are traveling all over the
country is to go to where their children
have been forced to live and laugh at
them this is what Boomers like to do
they go that you pay this for that
that's the whole point anytime a boomer
gets in a plane it is so that the plane
land and they can go uh to their child
uh their children's house and go oh my
God this is what this is what you're are
living in this is how you live and the
reason for that is because Boomers
refuse to sell their houses boomers are
85 years old riddled with four Cancers
and will not sell their house unless
they make $900,000
they have impoverished an entire
generation of people that cannot get
into the real estate market because
Boomers themselves refuse to leave
there's all kinds of articles about this
now and it's hilarious Boomers will not
relinquish their hold on Suburban real
estate in America they won't they won't
do it if they took a little less money
for example for their house if the
Boomers went you know what I'll take a
little less money for this house and
I'll I'll just put it back on the market
so that someone
else could have a shot but boomers are
sitting there they've got 17 pills they
take every day just to stay
alive and they pick up the phone and the
real estate agent goes maybe we could do
this we can get you this and they go
absolutely not
you will never get this
house for under
1.9 they refuse to leave because it's
their biggest
cudata the the the Boomer having a
mcmansion in in a place like Long Island
is the thing that they have that allows
them to they're the lord of the manner
and they can they can impress upon their
children what failures they are because
they don't live in the in the style that
the Boomers live in now the Boomers of
course will leave out all the advantages
they had to get said house but they will
not relinquish that because that is the
thing that they have you know this is
the thing that they have this is the way
that they judge there was an article why
Boomers will not move into uh more size
appropriate homes which I love because
boomers
are you know if if anything
are selfish they like
themselves which makes them funny that's
what makes them really really funny um
and the reason that they won't leave
these houses is because they cannot
imagine trying to
live in in in a more simple way even in
like the Twilight of their days in the
Twilight of their day is they need more
space and then their Millennial children
can't afford any of this so they're on
planes now complaining about everything
waiting for the plane to land so their
first stop is going to go to their
children's house and then go oh my God
you're it's so small here it's very
small I mean I feel so bad for your
gener you know when we were coming I
mean we worked harder than you guys of
course and we had a lot more to deal
with but you know at least you got
something for your m money you got a
little Ser it's like you're the reason
you the reason we we have the oldest
Congress in American history these
people will not retire Boomers hold on
for dear life to everything to
everything they are falling down in the
halls of Congress they will not leave
they will not quit this is why the world
looks the way it does it's being run
exclusively by like elderly Boomers who
will not leave they they are afraid of
not running the show um you know they
will not yeah according to a recent Mara
Lynch retirement study of more than 3600
respondents 49% of retirees didn't
downsize in their last move and 30%
actually ended up moving into larger
homes this is how
sick some of these people are they go
I'm aund and I want more I want a bigger
home I want a bigger home to show my
kids what losers they really are that's
really what it comes down to I want a
mansion now to show my kids how much
better I've done than them they will not
let go they will not let go Diane what's
her name a Feinstein died in office she
was a corpse for years died in off our
president he will not step aside he
won't step
aside it's it's it's kind of a thing to
the the whole Boomer thing is just hold
on to it hold on for dear life but I see
them you know when you get on a plane
obviously there's people of all ages but
you'll just kind of key in on the
Boomers and they're just kind is very
judgmental and you know they're in like
economy plus you know they paid just a
little bit more they've paid just a
little bit more so they can harass the
flight
attendant a standard deviation more than
the people in the back they have a
little bit of status and maybe some of
them are in first who knows but they're
all just traveling to some City where
their children live and they can go and
judge them for how they live right and
they never make the connection that oh
none of us have put our homes back on
the market none of us have God forbid
taken a little bit less and simplified
Our
Lives you know so that we have we're
effectively locking out cuz by the way
guess who loves the black rocket
everybody giving everybody crazy money
the Boomers they go yeah you you give me
that 2 million they love it they love it
they'll tell you one of the favorite
pastimes of anyone over a certain age
they'll tell you what they can get for
their house immediate you don't you
don't even ask you do not even and they
do it on holidays like on Christmas and
stuff they didn't they know why they're
doing it too they know exactly why
they're doing it they sit immediately
they go yeah yeah they go you want to
hear something crazy
and you're like and usually when someone
says that you want to hear something
crazy you would think they're going to
tell you something crazy you know like
some crazy story they heard when a
boomer says you want to hear something
crazy they just want to tell you the
exact amount of money they have that's
exact they go no no no come here listen
to this I bought this for 200,000 you
know what they tell me I could get now
1.8 isn't that something but guess what
I ain't leaving friend or two